[Music]
wild fire victims forced out of their
homes in Northern California have been
returning to see the devastation
firsthand thousands of them are stuck
with no place to live in the middle of a
severe housing shortage three California
wildfires in the last two months
destroyed more than 20,000 structures
the campfire was the state's most deadly
and destructive wildfire ever it killed
86 people and displaced an estimated
35,000 others Jamie yuccas shows us how
it's now nearly impossible for a vacuous
to find housing I lost everything that
I've had pictures pictures I could never
replace I mean a part of me feels really
selfish Burgess tabatha brewster and her
two daughters are starting over from
scratch their home was one of the nearly
fourteen thousand destroyed in the
campfire the family is using money from
FEMA to move from motel to motel brucer
wants to keep the girls in their school
so for now she drives them an hour each
way but she'd hoped to find a permanent
home nearby there's nothing there's no
place to live we're not equipped to
negotiate a disaster like this Edie
Mayer is the executive director of the
Housing Authority of Butte County as of
the date of the crisis there might be a
thousand units in Butte County that were
available all of those units are spoken
for now California was already facing a
housing shortage of almost a million and
a half units with the loss of tens of
thousands of homes to wildfires the
state is simply unable to absorb new
homeowners mayor says this disaster
could triple the number of homeless
people in his county to six thousand
we're playing musical chairs with
housing it takes someone to move out of
a unit for someone to secure a unit so
everyone's just waiting what do you do
in a situation like this well the
difficulty is is finding viable
alternatives
bringing in FEMA manufactured housing
units finding family or friends to live
with FEMA has approved roughly twenty
seven million dollars in housing grants
for campfire survivors and plans to
bring in thirteen hundred temporary
homes but mayor says rebuilding paradise
will likely take ten to twenty years an
unthinkable timeline for brewster and
her daughter's I think that every child
needs a little bit of stability and
there's no stability it makes me feel a
little bit of a failure but I couldn't
find something fast enough I can't live
in my house forever I'm hoping that
something comes together for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Chico California brewster
says that FEMA told her it will pay for
her motel stays for the next six to 18
months and that should get the family
through the end of the school year when
they can make a new plan about where to
live and she is not a failure she's a
hero for trying to keep some regularity
in her children she's a survivor yes
glad she's getting a little bit of help